Yet that the deep ecology idea
that we're just part of the fabric of
life with every other living thing and
that the despair we feel for the future
of the planet is the despair of all life
forms on the earth. So the ritual
involves expressing that the spear.
And then. Creating a.
Selecting an item of
landscape of a species
or something to represent in the council
of all beings and then you make a mask
and then you come to the council as
that creature or item a landscape
and you find voice to speak for it.
And this is a very powerful ritual.
It's a very powerful bonding experience
for people who are involved in rainforest
action or you know action
for the environment
and it's also very powerful at giving
people voice who they they find the
confidence and the voice to speak
what they really are concerned about.
So this this particular ritual. Is.
Kind of central to the work
that john seeds been doing
and the rainforest information centre
and the rainforest action groups around
australia who are defending the environment
the people who have committed their
lives to being on the frontline for the
environment. And only possible.
In this area
that it was born here because there were
a sufficient concentration of people
committed to developing
these works in their life.
So later manifestation or
current is conflict resolution
and negotiation skills of become a
major currency up here and people.
Than the new settlers in this area do this
very well. And it's taken the shape of.
An annual conference call the hut politics
conference where social activists come
together and discuss what's
been happening in their lives.
You know particularly if they've
been the spare and burn out
and take you hard find you.
Hard working together
and talk about techniques of
creating nonviolent social action.
The challenge is an enormous
big changes are coming in.
Big changes are going to
be made how to do this.
Non-violently how to create a safe.
Compassionate and culturally rich
community is the challenge of the times
and i see it happening here all the
time i worked in melbourne and sydney.
I did not see it.
I didn't see it expressing itself in
community the way i see it happening on the
north coast.
What about.
Forever and forever.
Well not all the turnings of the.
Not all parts of the aquarius dreams
for professions purposes fruit.
You know. Some of the fruit
turn sour on us and.
One of the observations i have about the.
The drug scene was that it was
part of the aquarius dream
that drugs were a liberation.
We were greatly influenced
by timothy leary huxley
stuff about doorways to perception
they would open your mind.
We're about expanded awareness
and i'm quite clear
that the aquarius festival wouldn't
have happened without the influence of
marijuana and allusions i mean that
was one of the cultural stimulants
that opened our minds to alternatives.
But when it was combined with
the necessities of economics.
And in the problem of never.
Not being able to have a gate
and discriminating about the
people who were coming in
and camping i know i'm a
strong enough to say no.
We had a number of things happening. You
know we can look back on it and say that.
Marijuana as a community sacrament
has a lot of downsides.
We can say well what happened was that.
People smoke a lot of marijuana
they grew it themselves.
So it was always readily available
a lot of people blew their minds
that way with marijuana because
it got stronger and stronger.
I mean they were doing selective
breeding and testing at themselves.
It results in a lot of
lethargy in the community.
We have a lot of people who have ideas
about how things ought to happen
but very little action very little people.
Able to actually bring it all together.
Sit down
and make have a meeting that's clear enough
to make agreements marijuana does not
assist meetings.
A lot of the early troubles we have with
meetings was that people were stunned
when they came to them they weren't
responsible for what they were saying they
unloaded stuff
and they couldn't hear marijuana stops
people from hearing what other people have
got to say. And then there was the
market side of marijuana that.
The good thing about it was that
it provided a means of income
and to build lots of houses in
the state area there are a lot.
Grass castles in this.
Truth of it provided people with income
and allowed them to lift
themselves out of poverty
and improve the conditions of the
family but the other side of
that was it introduced the
nullity people got easy money
and so they dismissed the
idealism of the query
and dreams as irrelevant what the real
world is about is making money mate
and doing deals and being
smart about the drug deals.
So we had a what's called the deal ocracy
that people who are smart at selling
drugs thought themselves to be superior
and apart from what was
going else was going on.
There's associate that with this fear and
paranoia. None of these things make.
For community safe community.
So in the old days you know you should be
able to grow your marijuana garden patch
and that be safe.
Not now people have been known to been
busted people coming in with guns
and stealing marijuana patches
and was kind stuff whole
communities fallen apart because.
The growers a fortnight for amongst
themselves on the community
and had such a siege mentality.
They didn't want visitors
what this you know
that the community ceased
to work as a community.
It was just a drug growing cooperative.
So there are lots of downsides
and then we had the problem
of women being too open.
So that during the 80s
when they grow government
and governments around australia
began closing down mental hospitals
and putting patients on the road and same
community should like look after them.
The family should look after them.
What we got was a policeman all round
australia saying want to go to nimbin.
And women being inundated with
the walking wounded. And.
How can i say the addicted.
I remember in the late 70s
and a group of 16 year old alcoholics from
the western suburbs as nimbin descended
on them then. And expected
to be looked after.
I remember in the late mirror in the
late eighties the late 70s a group of
16 year old 70 year old alcoholics from the
western suburbs of sydney descended on
nimbin and want to believe
that this was the new age
and the new age would look
after people like that
and it would tolerate their behaviour
and their behaviour was disgusting.
They were drunk most of the
time. An abusive. Richard lee.
Dissolute. And proud of it.
They saw themselves as being new-age
punks who are there to shock.
We old aquarians into a
new sense of reality.
And they did we were shocked.
We reported but were unable
to do anything about it and
that became the model for people
that followed i mean one of these guys is
dead now another one's on a mad pension
blew his brains. These were desperate
cases people who wanted to be dead.
This is total neil ism.
We're talking about the future
and suddenly we had to deal with neil us
who had no future and on top of that.
There you know the rejects the walking
wounded who arrived in town from.
Closed mental hospitals who expected
to be look after looked after.
I remember there was the case of a. Torrent
strait islander who came to the town.
And he was very black.
He was about five foot four tall and
five foot four across the shoulders and
when he got some alcohol in
him he was angry and violent.
He was looked after by the community.
He was fed for free in rainbow cafe and
asked to do some chores just sweep
and they would happily contribute to
that he was a you know sober he was a
really nice guy to talk to the community.
But when drunk he put his fist through
the plate glass window of the roma cafe
when that and another occasion
he raped two women and one night
and it kind of all falls
and the next day you sleeping off his
alcoholic father in the tomato sauce
and.
Some guys came into town from town who
falls approached the tomato sauce
put balaclavas on their face
and pulled out some four before for
me to from underneath their coats
and beat the guy up beating about the legs
to learn no it wasn't on this is bad.
News
when you community has been giuliani's
what other expression was there i heard
that this guy left town.
Shortly after that he did
get the message and i heard
that he was one of the
deaths in custody and
that was like it was
like the situation was.
If you can't survive in the man
you can't survive anywhere.
You know more compassion more tolerance
in the other community i've been to
and it was much lee abused.
So what's happened more recently
is like the street drug scene
had got very. It's being attended to. Now
but for a while there it got very bad.
Smack moved in.
I couldn't imagine that
smack would come to them
and we always thought in the 70s that
it required more money than that
but of course marijuana generated its
own income and its own drug trade.
So there was an exchange people would bring
back smack exchange for marijuana and.
Nimbin became a holiday
resort for junkies road.
If you're living on the back streets of
you know fitzroy and you had a habit.
You heard about this wonderful place we can
get any drug you want within 10 minutes
and why not go for a holiday
and him and so them
and developed its own hard
drug scene. And this.
This makes in another sense is like niman
being a prophetic community it's only
acting out what's happening
in other other cities
but doing much more blatantly a much
more up front than anywhere else.
It's true but niman only
has one main street
and this maxine is right smack in the
middle of it and visitors coming to them
and don't see the new age optimism
the rainbow power company.
What they see is whacked out people.
No light in their eyes at all.
No optimism no future.
And it's kind of got.
Institutionalized. You know
like there's sufficient.
Some traction to have its own mores
and its own defense not easily
moved not easily hidden
and.
Not a great advertisement for any means.
No more sense of failure and then when
any community trying to deal with.
The effect of drugs and i like. I agree
with what what i said about this.
The problem is the law
probably creates the problem.
If marijuana and heroin
were available legally and
and controlled in the same way as.
The spy of alcohol and cigarettes
and nicotine as controlled we wouldn't
have the markets duration we wouldn't have
the economy that supports the scene and.
All the downside of it would
be removed it can be treated.
They could be addressed
as a community problem.
But while we have a covert there's no way
you can bring the forces of light onto it.
You know like you can't
have active programs.
You can't create a community.
Rehabilitation program that's going to
work because they the culture of the
addiction is self-supporting. You know.
Anyway it's a nutty problem
but i've got more hope name
and i'll do something creative
about it than anywhere else
but it's like it's one of the things
that nieman inherit it from aquarius
it has its dark side shadow side.
And talking of shadows. And we talk
about this other aspect of name and.
That. When we're organising
the queries festival.
We heard this rumour
that was coming from the aboriginal
community in melbourne of all places
that nimbin had a curse upon it.
It was the valley you'd been curst they
said that they've been a massacre there
and. A cursed been put on by the aboriginal
people that now. What ever prosper.
That happened at valley until
somehow the curse was lifted.
So i was really interested
to find out about this.
That was part of the mythmaking of
the festival. And i went chasing.
Aboriginal leaders in the area searching
them out to find out what they knew about
it and i came to nothing.
You know i met uncle lyle.
And who was an aboriginal
elder at the time.
And he knew nothing about or if he did
he wasn't willing to talk about it
but the words that were said were
when i asking about spiritual issues
what i got back were christian. Words.
So i my feeling was a bunch of people
have been so effectively christianized
that they did not know the story anymore.
If it wasn't immediately available.
So we went into the festival
with that hanging over us
and a couple of years in about 1977 i
had an opportunity to visit kath walker
stradbroke island.
And it was had a remarkable night
with catherine and her campfire.
Which she showed us some of her
shaman abilities shaman powers
and of poetry and the madness of all
that counts that one of those nights
and in the course i told her the story
of nim and what was happening there
and she expressed interest
in finding out more
and i was interested to find
out the aboriginal story.
So i invited catwalk to come to nimbin
and stay with us for a while and he did
and she stayed with a friend at the
end of a weeks day i went to see her
and i say well what do you think
what you know and she said that.
She was feeling worse
that newman was male initiation
ground very strong country.
That this is not good for women.
So it's not a place where
women are going to prosper.
So take that into account and the other
thing. I think about it is that.
It's a place where people come to learn.
Young men coming for initiation
and if you stay too long.
You don't get the initiation if
you don't learn and move on.
Then you'll turn to stone.
That the rocks will take the energy
back they take the teaching back
and you'll be become rigid and.
I got this message in 1977 the
battle of trainee creek was 1978
and i was like i felt developed only greek
for me was like as much as i could do in
community organization. I mean i got what
i wanted the community was strong enough.
You know it was working as a community
and i did fictive leave been marginalized
by my radical stand on the forest fight
so
that any time i try to do anything you know
i had a chorus of voices saying shut up.
Stop. Don't do anything more
you caused me much trouble.
I began to realize that my initiation
was oprah's time for me to move on.
So those words had a personal meaning
for me but i also observe them in them
but.
They say
that part of the drug problem in yemen is
young people because the drug market the
drug dealers in the middle.
Usually in typically people selling drugs
to tourist typically 100 18 year olds
who lack appropriate initiation.
They're part of the man
who is off the rails
and it needs stronger initiation to bring
them in line also is that when you.
If this is 40 thousand years old
this wisdom about this country
and if you ignore it. You
do so at your peril.
And it's as if if you muck
around with that kind of energy.
It has its own entity a.d.
You know so what was was a positive thing
for learning turns in on itself and.
In the shadows reveal themselves.
So you know the sense that
there's an image as a metaphor
when hear about the social problems an
imminent drug problem has been generated
being the shadow of the aquarian dream.
Because somehow the land is being abused
somehow not enough respect is being taken
the energy that that
valley inherently has. So.
Name and it's my. Mother
joy mother of despair.
It broke my heart broken open.
And.